the portal erich von Stein's new show
the first episode featured Peter Thiel
it was such an incredible episode and
I'll be breaking down key highlights the
first thing that I thought was so
profound that they talked about was this
idea of orchards of low-hanging fruit
what that means is that there are
certain knowledge patches that
civilization has been going to over time
and trying to gather these low-hanging
fruit of knowledge from those knowledge
patches and we can think about this with
how we discovered certain things like
fire how he discovered language how we
discovered art how we discovered writing
and books and the Industrial Revolution
agricultural revolution the this now new
hockey-stick of exponential technologies
there's all these little tiny fruits
that are lowest-hanging in these
orchards in biology in physics in
mathematics and in emotional
intelligence and spirituality and we
have to go and we have to find where
these orchards are and we also have to
recognize when we're exhausting the
orchards when we have to sometimes we
have to find these big ladders and we
have to go and try and climb up really
high to get these these fruits that are
no longer low-hanging but they're medium
or high hanging fruits and those are
harder to get and so it takes more
resources more humans and more time
maybe more AI to try and get to those
fruits so we can always move to new
patches and and who knows about this
word always right how far does this edge
of knowledge go but we can continue
moving to new patches orchards and
finding low-hanging fruits and we'll
revisit this concept later on as well so
we've been they also really talked about
the stagnation that was happening the
stagnation in science and technology and
how that's stagnating our culture and
our development and so one of the things
that I think is really important here is
that you can find these embedded growth
obligations in law firms you can find
them in the
university system where as Peter and
Eric explained partners hire associates
that hope to become partners and then
hire associates with law firms or
university systems every professor
treats graduate students to become
research professors to then train
graduate students and so the time for
these embedded growth obligations has
run out institutions have become
pathological sociopathic that's a very
interesting way to view it that these
embedded growth obligations will
sometimes continuously just be trying to
reward shareholders money and sucking
value from a system rather than trying
to actually create value create more
value than you capture such an important
first principle and we saw it when the
tech bubble we saw it with the housing
bubble we sought with this government
loans bubble so it can't no longer be a
fringe view if civilizations at a time
of tech stagnation of spiritual
stagnation of scientific stagnation it's
so important for us to admit that we are
there and we need to get ourselves out
of there as fast and effectively as
possible and that we need to respect
people that think that way and engage
them with dialogue and not say you can't
talk about that and just wave them down
with political correctness and say you
can't do that the economy is fantastic
right now we need to get over these this
intellectual dishonesty that we're
propagating this meme of dishonesty
across our own ethos and across our own
civil societies advancements were lying
to young people and saying that if you
go to these institutions that you will
leave with the sheet of paper and that
you will get a job that will help you
repay these 200,000 dollars of debt we
need to think of things like this teal
fellowship think of things like how do
you get 13 year olds that are really
passionate about a specific field to the
edge of that field as fast as possible
by the time they're 17 they can be
making the next massive advancements
with the right mentors around them but
we're not thinking that way we need to
start thinking that way and helping
children achieve what they're really
passionate about fast and again we're
revisiting this concept of this at these
orchards of low-hanging fruit because it
seems like the biological
evolution was really around these 1950s
of the discovery of the double helix of
the discovery of the human genome and
mapping it and then why is it taking 50
70 years for us to make this era of the
social genome finally happening that
things like this Carlson curve that we
could have potentially had much earlier
is only really kicking off now with the
decreased costs and costs and sequencing
and the speed and sequencing and that
all these new cast enzymes that were
finding the way for us to do these
genetic engineering technologies for us
to probe and understand how how all of
the different microbes and bacteria
across our planet have evolved and what
interesting insights we can take from
them and apply in biotech why is it
taken this long why is it so interesting
that we're in this biology orchard but
we're why are we not capturing these
low-hanging fruits and how do we do that
better as a civilization and how do we
work together with the United States and
China and other intelligence bodies
across the planet to work together on
figuring that out also another huge
aspect about these institutions and even
in culture in general is that there's
this no polymaths rule allowed that you
can't be someone of wide-ranging
knowledge you can't go and see how a
specific field meshes with another
specific field because then the people
in that field will say they're not
really serious about the depth of that
field
well actually typically what happens is
when you mesh together two different
fields what you do is you gain unique
insights about each field that other
people aren't thinking about that's so
important
bridging together different abstract
fields and seeing how they cope play in
interplay is such so critical for
pushing the edge of knowledge further in
finding new discoveries and innovating
that we need that we need more polymaths
we need more people breadth is the new
depth and we need to make that more
common around our world finding these
unique connections that are so
frequently just buried under the rug by
culture and saying that you're not going
to figure anything out you're not going
innovate you're not going to get a new
job and it's so unfortunate that within
these embedded growth obligations that
institutions that there's this a notion
that they have to keep convincing the
government and the alumni that that
there's that there's nothing going on
wrong and that everything is great
versus actually being able to step up
and say that hey no not everything is
great
there are certain aspects of our
institutions that are sociopathic that
are pathological and we need to fix them
and we need to innovate on our
institutions like our universities we
need to innovate on these embedded
growth obligations in private sector as
well we need to really think about what
is the trajectory of our future what is
the teleology of human civilization what
is our end goal what is our purpose and
how do we maximize our potential in
getting there the debt has gotten
ridiculous of student loans 1.7 trillion
that the over-promising is continuing to
happen you see young kids that are being
constantly pulled out of creative
endeavoring and funneled into the
education system of universities
promised these excellent outcomes
whereas really they could achieve way
more excellent outcomes by finding
mentors pursuing entrepreneurship
pursuing art and creativity at younger
ages meshing together these abstract
fields we need to make that more common
a great way to put this is to ask this
question of how would you redesign
civilization that question can help a
lot how would you redesign the
institutions that are becoming
pathological how would you redesign our
civil society to make it more effective
at achieving our end goals to make it
more just to make the opportunities more
equal for people to self actualize and
bring their unique gifts to the world
and that question needs to be talked
about with our family with our friends
with our co-workers people online
redesign civilization
look around everywhere you look and
think about how you would redesign and
reengineer things to be better we talked
about this this so important polymaths
remember that word go and learn much
across different disciplines and find
those unique connections and also think
about what is the point of all this what
is the natural teleology of the human
race on this rock orbiting the star what
is the point in many ways it is a
massive big artistic expression of
creation that we're all here and that
it's then our goal to help children to
find out what is their North Star they
remember that they come from source and
that we all do and that then we
artistically express ourselves each
individually creatively with the Nash
equilibrium so that we also bring our
gifts to society at the same time and
that we create more value than we
capture these are critical principles
for children and for adults to remember
and it's a huge problem that all the
people that are using the word equality
are forgetting that we all have
individual unique skill sets and that
those unique skill sets are so critical
there are a bunch of little competence
hierarchies that exist across the world
which is why certain people are good at
making food and other people are good at
giving and getting us electricity and
when you think about that then you say
okay let them be good at doing what they
do and let's see how we can trade
between those two to make it easier for
us all to live and pursue what we
actually care about so we have to
remember to recognize our unique gifts
as unique skill sets but we do need an
equality of opportunity for people to
pursue with an equal degrees of economic
freedom for people to pursue what they
love in the world and this is also an
interesting point that Eric brought up
and Peter said that you're not going to
get a conversion this time but it may be
true that this median individual in the
future may not be able to defend a
position to make a family
and we'll see because Peter had multiple
times claimed that the speed of
automations nowhere near what people are
claiming it to be in that there will
always be these different jobs available
and whatnot and so this is kind of a
massive contrasting point to the memes
that people like Andrew yang are
propagating and that both of these
statements are very true that in many
ways Silicon Valley is not at pace the
world of these bits is moving so fast
but the world of the atoms is moving so
slow and are we actually making these
steps in automation because if we were
what so many more things be automated by
now when we already have figured out
nuclear fusion for a sustainable source
of energy what do we have already not
figured out how to map our entire
biometric state to make it easier for us
to live longer to restore our youthful
homeostatic capacity faster all these
things are such interesting points and
principles to keep in mind but also will
it be that with this rush of mimetics
that now people are spending their lives
spreading memes and ideas to eight
billion people instead of having genes
and their genes spreading through having
children that maybe then is that that
the idea of me spreading my own memes
out is actually more important and then
I'm not gonna focus as much on having
kids and so maybe this idea of the
family in the future is gonna be
completely different and with the
designer baby era and all these ideas
that we have ahead of us that the notion
of a family may be completely different
and to be able to still the have
families is going to be important and
for people to be able to afford to do
that is gonna be important and we'll see
exactly where automation takes us in
that in that area
okay we need less people talking about
relying on the government for help
there are edge cases of vulnerable
people and Eric was mentioning this and
this is why I love Eric so much he's
super Polymathic and he's also able to
identify these vulnerable edge cases
when people are vulnerable they need our
help and that's totally true people with
any physical or mental disabilities
absolutely need our help to fully
creatively actualize their own potential
into the world and to have a fun and
engaging time on this planet and so we
do need to figure out how to structure
the programs that assist that but just
in general we the idea of me being able
to rely on the government versus me
being able to rely on myself and knowing
that I can then bring some sort of a
divine potential to reality that is way
more important and so less less people
talking about relying on government and
more people talking about containing
control of their own destiny
and coordinated social action for the
vulnerable as we said do not use ad
hominem attacks to try and attack people
rather than talk about their ideas
remember the principle of Steel manning
steel man instead of straw man don't
misrepresent people's arguments to make
them easy to defeat but build up on
their arguments and then you can
showcase whether or not their critical
thinking was incorrect or maybe you can
add on top of it
this idea of dining a la carte is very
interesting in many ways it comes from
Greek eclectic O's or eclecticism that
you can take ideas from disparate
seemingly disparate fields add them into
some beautiful new synthesis and then
make your worldview more robust so again
dine a la carte from different buffets
of thinking and teal cares a lot about
growth leading to the reduction of
violence I think that's so critical and
important to talk about so remember to
put a flag in that that we do not want
stagnation because stagnation can result
in more violence and that as we continue
growing we can decrease the amount of
violence more
people can increase the standards of
living more people can creatively
actualize on the in the world I think
this was really important that Peter and
Eyre got to how World War two and
Germany was actually a big duel wound
happened between Germany and the and the
Jews that it's still seeping into the
culture today between Germany and the
Jewish spirit for both of them it's
still seeping this wound it's a dual
wound that happened and we need to
prevent these dual wounds from emerging
there's still so many of these of these
conflicts that are occurring
geopolitically across our planet and for
us to be able to remember that every
time we embark on one of these violent
conflicts against each other
geopolitically that it creates a dual
wound in our ethos and then we have to
do this this tedious process of healing
and of integrating that trauma over
multiple generations and it's been
happening for the longest time since the
start of civilization and we really need
to figure out how to do that less and to
figure out how to have more peace but to
still have mimetic parallax where we're
still working on bettering and bettering
a civilization over time not stagnation
with peace but peace for cooperation and
then continuously compete on ideas to
maximize prosperity and then trauma
causes the loss of intellectual dynamism
and there's also some trauma there's
also some treasures on the other side of
traumas as well there's some learning
lessons these ideas of orphaned or
unpopular theories so if you take these
edge theories and you try and integrate
them more into the social fabric
typically you'll see people that are
trying to in many ways do that process
of scapegoating that Rene Girard was
talking about as well and Peter had an
air convention but just that you want to
come in as a one-percenter and into a
place of 99%
homogenized thinking because what you
can do is you can then start poking at
people's perspective bubbles and try and
augment their perspective you do if
we're talking about an Overton Window
and we're talking about being at one of
these edges of the bell curve a couple
standard deviations out and people
aren't realizing what you're saying yet
finding people that are closer to your
position on the bell curve and
recruiting them over you're trying to
move the Overton Window towards progress
and so to move the Overton Window
towards progress you need to be able to
have these orphaned or unpopular
theories that come back into play with
this edge thinking that then move the
Overton Window over they also talked
about preference falsification one set
of public preferences one set of private
preferences and in many ways they
explained this with how so many people
in Silicon Valley have made it such a
monoculture of thinking where you can't
actually talk about any sort of
conservative principles and that make it
really hard for people to talk freely
and truthfully about how they feel and
how they can how you can better have a
syncretic politics I can bring the left
and right together to help build up
ideas instead it just immediately
polarizes and so political correctness
in general being one of the biggest
problems in the world putting pressure
on people to say things that they don't
mean that's so important that we have to
eliminate that people have to feel free
to express themselves and have a really
powerful art of conversation of having
great empowering conversations where you
can build up on top of each other's
points find the nuance finally multi
variability and then be able to take
progressive action on how you want to
make the world better the intellectual
dark web is a bipartisan coalition that
that's super important and it's super
true to the ethos of the intellectual
dark web there's so much nuance there's
so much multi variability on a cross
who's in it what they talk about and the
importance of what they talk about so
remember that it's a bipartisan
coalition and that's one of these
seemingly main reasons why mainstream
media is not trying to talk about the
intellectual dark web
they're always mainstream media is
almost always propagating binary memes
to propagating one-sided thinking but
the IDW is heavily concentrated on
nuanced thinking don't get distracted
from these really important things
especially when so much sociopathic
behavior is occurring with the phishing
to get clicks on things
maybe sociopathic behavior is needed to
get people's attention so that you can
stay more relevant so there's this kind
of dichotomous thinking with that but
nuanced thinking is much harder to get
people to click on right now because
it's more cognitively challenging it's
more cognitively easing to find
something that's binary to make it easy
to make a pro point in your worldview
but it's way harder to find something
that's a nuanced and the min the mimetic
theory of Rene Girard and how imitation
can engender point pointless conflict in
general we are very imitative species so
that we do things that very frequently
imitate each other especially with these
things like embedded growth obligations
that all of a sudden one of these
contracts for one of these companies
looks exactly like the same contract the
same company and we're not and then all
the company's contracts look exactly the
same and all of the law firms are making
the same damn contracts for the same
companies and they're not innovating or
iterating on what could be better
and then religion was necessary and
evolution to control the violence that
came from mimetic rivalry that was very
important and also that we work years of
our time for transient materialistic
possessions we must do our best to
realize that the the things that we take
on as material possessions are really
important to just help us become more
well being as well as more artistically
expressing into the world so getting
things that help you your family your
community Society
both have better well-being and also
better actualization and bringing your
gifts of the world it's critical but you
can literally feel when you take things
in as materialistic possessions and you
work your ass off for them and then they
just sit there and they don't do
anything it's just really annoying so
really and it's it's and it's actually
it's counterintuitive because you you're
part of the economy by working to earn
money to get that thing and that it's
actually that whole process is broken
because you could have spent that time
doing something else that was more
actual izing that actually brought the
world more value you're likely to get
scapegoated if you don't take them if
you don't take a reference in the herd
and push the edge of knowledge so this
is a very good point is that if you do
take this place in the herd we're in the
99% like we were saying before where you
can kind of just disappear into the rest
of the herd you will not likely get
targeted but the one percenters that
come with these fringe theories in to
try and push the Overton Window are like
most likely to get uniquely identified
and then scapegoated so we have to be
also have to be very careful this is why
we see so many anonymous deployments of
a civilization updates like the
decentralization technologies that
satoshi nakamoto deployed why was it
done so anonymously well maybe in the
future it's going to be these anonymous
updates that make it so that the Overton
Window can get pushed by people that
don't have ad hominem attacks on to this
satoshi nakamoto but instead people are
critiquing the idea over time instead
and we have to respect the burden of
genius in general these fringe theories
that come in to try and push the Overton
Window we have to respect them we have
to actually have deep interlocked eating
experiences with them dialectic
experiences where we can push poke and
probit their theories build up on top of
them see if they can stand the test of
our critique to see if they are the best
ways to progress civilization forward
and remember that the more self-dealing
that we have the more trauma we have
especially with things like
institutional betrayal that it's going
to be so important for us
to not let these fake foods these fake
politicians these fake physicians these
fake teachers these fake life coaches
these fake spiritual leaders to let them
is seep into our ethos to stay really
vigilant about all of the inputs that we
take in especially inputs into our
health as well and into our mind and our
spirit and that what we can do is we can
gain a really good amount of robust
ethos suit the way that we take those
inputs in share that with our friends
and family and try and decrease the
amount of fake foods make politicians
fake news etc that's propagating around
the world and focus on these things that
can we were talking about this yesterday
on one of our interviews that there we
have this beautiful library of life
experience that's stored in us and then
of the neurodegenerative diseases they
basically they burn our library down of
what unique things we've stored and if
we can radically extend life we can do
things like add more books to our
library and make new connections and
make more creative input into our world
so these are really important things to
be focused on and to just shatter
through the intellectual stagnation and
the institutional stagnation in the
sociopathic and pathologic behaviors of
both institutions and the private sector
and the government sector and make
things a little bit more lean but keep
in mind the vulnerable people that need
help too this has been a summary of some
of the things that that Peter Thiel came
on to erich von stein show to talk about
the portal on the first episode it was
such a good episode I hope you guys have
enjoyed this little synthesis of it and
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below on what you think about
it I'd love to hear from you and also
you know support the different artists
the entrepreneurs the organizations the
spiritual leaders in your communities
that you believe and support them and
help them grow have more community
events around these thought-provoking
topics go and talk more on the internet
on social media about and family and
friends in the communities about these
about these different topics that we
talked about today talk more about them
and build more into our world on these
topics and support people like us our
show simulation where I hosted Allen
sake
and you can support us below we have
patreon cryptocurrency paypal down there
you can design cool merch and get paid
help support us we can keep doing cool
things like this and just build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we'll see
you soon peace